hi everyone it's jerry
let's have a look at a game from round
one
of the alt box norway chess tournament
2020.
an over the board tournament they're
back at it playing in person
classical time controls on the white end
jan christoph duda and he's paired
against ali reza farouja
so let's hop right in duda opening with
one e4
farouza opting for the caro khan defense
we have a mainline kerocon bishop
f5 and we follow this main line
for about 14 moves let me just sneak a
few more in there
pay particular attention to these next
two i'd like to highlight
an opening subtlety some of you may find
interesting
and that is knight f3 on move 7
threatening 95 attacking the bishop
black doesn't like the idea of that so
defends e5
and only now do we have h5
so what's the difference this is
something i have questioned
uh why not just play h5 on move
seven well here's a difference here's a
reason
to not go with h5 first it's that
when knight f3 is played there's no
longer this threat
the bishop isn't on g6 anymore so what
does this mean or what
can it mean well it can mean that once
black has a couple prep moves in
on the king's side such as e6
and knight f6 black can consider
playing c5 and then deploying the queen
knight
to its optimal post
on c6 okay
by playing knight f3 first this
is provoking knight d7
okay only now h5 the bishop on h7
is too good needs to go
bishop d2 tame deployment
but good out of reach of a knight when
he's on
when the knight is on d5 uh this bishop
will
kind of say i got you under control if
there's ever a knight arriving on that
square
a good post i've seen it eventually
relocate in some
variations to the c3 square after c4 is
played
okay continuing we have queen side
castles for white
king side for black the battle lines are
drawn
opposite sides castle's position who's
going to get it who's king first
let's see where do we go from here how
to improve
well identify a dummy piece this guy
here on g3
pretty sad so he's improved
and the g pun is ready to roll
c5 uh this move right here set duda back
into his seat uh
white's next move took 33 minutes
so what is what was white thinking about
here what is at least
one move he was considering
well in the game bishop e3 was played
what else was he considering
probably g4 this is a
thematic pawn sacrifice you need to be
familiar with
if you're going to play this line as
black
black takes rook to g1
this is the classic you give up some
material but you get some lines
towards the enemy king
this knight can't budge black has to
make these committal moves
like f5 yeah
very chaotic position uh
yeah the knight moves this is gonna get
busted it's already winning for white
anyhow this sacrifice with g4 is likely
something
white was weighing at this moment right
here on this move 15.
in the end he decided on bishop to e3
increasing some pressure increasing the
pressure on c5 trying to resolve this
tension
black now goes for a pawn sacrifice
ops to grab the knight on e4
improve the knight on d7
the b-pawn is up for grabs white takes
it and says show me
just as i was pointing out giving up the
knight pawn this g-pawn
black gave up their knight pawn and
black will now have
pressure against the white king how much
pressure
let's find out we have
knight to d5 this is already generating
a threat
you see the threat here
if g3 is played just to make a dummy
move
knight c3 you're getting the rook
oh and if you take the knight guess
who's excited about
getting to the uh b file there goes the
queen
okay so how do you parry this threat
you get your queen off of the same file
as the king
rook to b8 another threat
it's defended okay the bishop has the
knight under control
black takes on d4 recapture
bishop f6 pressure against the knight
knight to b3 let's get a few more
moves in and pause move 22
how are things standing
excellent for black black is down upon
but has
more than enough compensation for it
every black piece is better than
their counterpart um if there is
what is it about this position that
sticks out to me most
the quality of the knights this guy on
d5
is a beast the knight on b3
uh not well positioned at all and pinned
notice the nice coordination black has
striking at b2
this is a real problem
for white so let's see how
white tries to untangle also note
there's some pressure on c2 so that's
it's defended with rook to c1 never a
fun move to make
going from an open file to a closed file
to simply babysit upon
but here we are that's where it is
uh that's the position white finds
himself in right now
babysitter mode okay knight to b6 if you
thought the knight on d5 was a pest when
you see him on
c4 two different checking squares
and yeah that b2 point is really
having some pressure on it okay so what
is white coming up with he's trying to
get the queens off
rook to e4 a support point for now
bishop f4 a skewer
is white winning material no
there are there will often be plenty of
cases
where you can find your way
out of a tactic based on an unprotected
piece
in the position so in this case there's
an unprotected queen on a6
so the queen goes to b6 no time to take
the rook the queen would fall
in the game we have queen takes queen
rook takes queen
so if you find yourself in a similar
scenario
as this uh one of the squares that
should be lighting up in your mind
or when the squares i think that would
be a good idea to have
lit up in your mind is the intersection
square between these two pieces
this square in particular okay
sometimes a queen maybe a rook in some
variations
all right in this game it's queen b6
the queens are off white is still up a
pawn
is the attack over the queens are off
it's not over the pressure
is still there every one of black's
pieces
is still better than white's pieces
and this a pawn right here is just a
couple moves away from scaring this
knight
yeah and if this knight has to move if
this knight has to move that b2 pawn
yeah if that pawn falls it's over
so let's see what white tries to come up
with here
trying to simplify but
yeah it's not going to be easy no time
to take this pawn
farouza is ducking this threat here and
generating a threat of his own
right the knight's ready to move and
there goes the unprotected rook
so some security for the rook on e4
against
against this threat and here comes the
apon
ready to scare the knight away at this
point the pressure is so much
that yeah that night white deems it as
intolerable needs to go
just to highlight another attempt
if you think about maybe c3 in this
position
scaring the rook away
that's not going to work either uh
you know c3 with the idea to let's say
go to c2
and defend b2 that's not working because
a4 is still there
and after the knight moves can chop the
knight
and then take advantage of this pin
and there goes the exchange
so white is in a serious pickle
gives up the exchange he has a pawn for
it
we enter some imbalanced position a very
good decision
i feel on white's part get rid of that
night
so let's see how this next phase
plays out it's turned very imbalanced
right now white has three connected past
pawns but they are all still home
are they a serious threat not yet
will they ever be a threat that's
another question
let's see rick goes back to the b
file he just quickly plucked that pawn
on the h
file there's now a four to two majority
for white excuse me for black
on the king side now returns it makes
white work a little bit harder before
this knight can actually move so
bishop d2 how to make progress
here get those pawns rolling
rook moves i don't know if any rook
moves by black
uh is really an improvement the bishop
uh it's optimally placed there it's on
the main diagonal so
pawn play right around this stage c3
blunting this diagonal the king is now
ready to improve
g5 king c2 g4 right around
here there's a turning point
considered best as a capture on f3
and then working with this past h pawn
but instead we have
g3 with the intention to create a past
g pawn one day but it's gonna require
a successful h3 pawn break
and that's not uh
a guarantee and no guarantee that black
can successfully get in that h3 move
can these guys get rolling let's see
first it's b3 a4 some progress by white
now
knight e2 improving the night post
pressure on g3
that's defended white gets the pawns
rolling
e5 bishop e3 bishop g5
dark square bishops are gone pressure on
h3
rook h5 an interesting moment right here
this pawn is defended but
this rook is unprotected there's a pin
here
in the game we have king c3
maybe preparing to next play b4 and c5
now that c4 is defended also you're off
of this second rank from a potential
check
what potential check am i referring to
well
a move that white can consider here
instead of king c3
the move played in the game is knight
takes g3
taking advantage of the pin
black can play rook g5 and after knight
e4 there's rook
takes g2 with check how exactly to
assess
this position i don't know it's too
tough
uh i really don't know how to assess
this one
uh it almost feels like it's easier to
play
as white uh
this guy is close to falling there's a
knight that's
super tricky these guys yeah kind of
scary
tough one to call this isn't something
he goes for
instead king c3 f5 there's still another
opportunity to take on g3
uh knight takes g3 here yeah it's
actually it's not as effective
because there's no longer knight to e4
so if you're going to play knight to g3
knight takes g3 it's best uh
best to actually capture at this very
moment move
44. instead king c3
black establishes a pawn on f3
these passers continue and this last one
move 46 was
a blunder and hard to blame
uh any player really from making a
blunder at this stage they're both
basically in bullet mode uh at this
stage there is a 10 second increment but
they're both under a minute
around this phase of the game this move
of the game
instead of a5 which turns out to be the
losing move of the game
uh surprisingly enough this
cringe move knight g1
is something to consider
uh yeah going back home and
making your rook look ridiculous for a
move
but the knight is going to be a very
efficient
defender against potential past pawns on
the king side
next up knight h3 activate the rook
and then work on these guys get them
advancing
uh i could easily see this i could see
this game go in either direction
if knight to g1 is on board uh
it may be the case black has to find
some very accurate moves in order to
stop
uh though these three connected passers
from
scoring a touchdown okay at the end of
the day there is not this
uh prophylactic move knight to g1
instead he gets marching
with a5 i'm not going to go into the
details on this but
the computer says that b5 is
actually a uh is still holding as a draw
so that was
a little interesting to me i
looked at the differences between these
two moves i think in general
when you're in these uh situations
you're low on time you just go with
whatever's instinctual to you
i think one train of thought would be
with a5 is you know what it's further
away from the black king he's gonna have
a harder time
tracking that pawn down uh a difference
here with b5
uh a difference that may run through a
chess player's mind is that with b5
there's a square now for the king to
move
uh forward up to b4 is vacated and also
uh if i can get to b7 i'd be hitting the
rook
i'm getting a maybe a valuable tempo
anyhow just a some train of thought to
share with you
okay in this game it is a5 and now we
have
h3 giving up a pawn
so that this guy is now passed
and after this move we have a very nice
moment captured
by leonard otis
the official photographer for this event
capturing duda uh yeah he's
i think trying his best to remain
concentrated
and farouza still contemplating his
47th move appears to me
to be cool as a cucumber
kind of has this i got this
look i'm in control
anyhow just moments later do we see
farouja's move
it is e4 giving up another pawn
after the capture on e4 we now have
seven
passers present five for white
two for black but
uh it is often the case with pawns it is
more so
about quality than quantity
these guys are extra dangerous
uh the deeper the pawns are the pawns
that have more depth
are often more dangerous they get
rolling in this case in this game
immediately
g2 with tempo the h pawn falls with
check king d4 f3
attacking the knight not really
white doesn't have to react to that
threat just yet
first plays c5 and now we have
one preventative move one prophylactic
move king f7 by black
taking the knight means that white will
be able to take on g2 with check
and then scoop up the e pawn and good
luck trying to stop
these says it's equal yeah
still some work to do to stop them
okay king f7 now black's ready to scoop
up the knight knight f4 was played
and after f2 white resigns
no time to take the rook take the rook
get a queen there is no stopping black
from getting a queen pawn
quality not quantity
that's the big takeaway from this game
this ending
at least that will
often surface quality over quantity
another variation at this stage
is king e3 this is something i tested
out
and after pawn takes knight king takes
pawn
uh black can go hunting for this guy
while white picks up the g pawn black
gets the b pawn and these guys are all
split
isolated weak and will easily be hunted
white has to worry even about maybe
getting mated soon
okay anyhow in this game it was knight
f4
and these two pawns at the end of the
day
we're too much okay
anyhow that's all for this video
feel free to leave any feedback in the
comment section below
i hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
you